[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
frança 24 hoy jueves 21 de julio rosa
pérez más deuda de nuevo en nuestro
estudio rosa por supuesto vamos a abrir
con la noticia del momento ayer
precisamente también lo hablamos con uno
de nuestros invitados del día y es la
crisis de gobierno que hay en italia
finalmente entonces el presidente sergio
mataré la aceptó la emisión del que esto
había primer ministro hasta que se
resuelva esa crisis y alguien que lo
suceda mario draghi recordemos rosa
también que esto se presentó ya pues
está esta semana hace unos días a cuando
él le presentó a la emisión materiales
le dijo usted de renuncia trate
obviamente de pues reconstruir esta
coalición de gobierno y precisamente
pues cuando trató de hacerlo los pues de
gente de su de su coalición de gobierno
le dijo pues no la apoyamos y ya
finalmente nada que hacer qué va a pasar
ahora pues todo puede pasar pero lo más
probable lo que se está manejando dentro
de las esferas del gobierno italiano es
que se llame el presidente sergio matar
el a por supuesto a unas elecciones
anticipadas y esto incluyó obviamente la
disolución
así las cosas en italia rosa como están
entonces registrando los periódicos la
noticia de este día pues bien raúl
buenos días la cuestión es que si bien
las crisis de gobierno siempre son
noticia ese particular el caso de italia
que vive en una crisis institucional
perpetua recordemos el dato que es que
en 76 años es decir desde el fin de la
segunda guerra mundial ha habido 67
gobiernos en italia y precisamente esta
caída del gobierno de draghi se ha dado
por la propia naturaleza de este
ejecutivo porque recordemos que mario
draghi no fue elegido en las urnas sino
que su rol es el de un tecnócrata al que
el presidente de italia matar ela le
pidió formar un gobierno de coalición de
unidad nacional a principios de 2021
precisamente para afrontar los retos
económicos y sanitarios de la pandemia
de kobe 19 y por eso él le ha dado tanta
importancia a perder el apoyo en el
parlamento de los partidos que formaban
su gobierno de coalición de unidad
nacional que eran partidos sobre todo
rosa en el ámbito económico recordemos
que él es jana supermario por el impulso
que le dió italia económicamente claro y
porque él recordemos es expresidente del
banco central europeo y de hecho esta
última crisis viene por el no apoyo del
movimiento cinco estrellas a una decreto
de ayudas económicas en todo caso los
titulares que encontramos en la prensa
italiana los vemos aquí con estas
imágenes no hace falta muchas palabras
pero básicamente la repubblica por
ejemplo dice italia traicionada draghi
pide una prueba de unidad nacional al
senado para seguir adelante pero salvini
berlusconi y conte le niegan la
confianza el parlamento víctima del
populismo y precisamente a un análisis
que encontramos de forma reiterada es
que los partidos de derecha y de extrema
derecha particularmente la liga que se
informaba parte de esta coalición y que
ha retirado el apoyo a draghi pero
también a los fratelli de italia este
partido de extrema derecha que no forma
parte de la coalición de unidad nacional
digamos que verían un su resultado ha
favorecido ante estas elecciones
anticipadas por lo que les interesa
nuestra caída del ejecutivo bien la
stampa titula vergüenza conté y salvini
und en el gobierno el milagro no sucedió
iremos a elecciones oa finales de
septiembre oa principios de octubre y
señala la stampa la importancia de hacer
emerger las responsabilidades quien
provocó la crisis el movimiento cinco
estrellas y quien la cabalgó cínicamente
la centroderecha no la forza italia de
berlusconi y la extrema derecha de la
liga de salvini y por último el
corrieron el corriere de la sera titula
adiós al gobierno drag y la liga fuerza
italia y movimiento cinco estrellas un
den al premier y dice sin ausencia de
novedad en las elecciones anticipadas
pues en breves instantes hablaba de
matteo salvini rosa necesidad no es
invitado del día de ayer que
posiblemente él pudiera ser uno de los
candidatos favoritos hasta el primer
ministro nos quedamos en el corriere
della sera' por que repasa hace eco
internacional de esta noticia rosa
exactamente porque como suele suceder
cuando uno y los medios de comunicación
de este país tienen la autopercepción de
lo que lo que sucede es importante a
nivel internacional digamos hacen a este
ejercicio de recoger los titulares de la
prensa alrededor del mundo y así lo ha
hecho el corriere della sera' ante esta
caída del gobierno drive que dice
interesa y preocupa a la prensa
internacional que sigue con atención lo
que sucederá en roma' en las próximas
horas por un lado te coge el titular de
la bbc- de la cadena de radio televisión
británica que dice el primer ministro
italiano falla en el intento de revivir
el gobierno the gardian draghi renuncia
tras el abandono de la mayoría
parlamentaria el 'new york times'
regresó de las turbulencias políticas la
inestabilidad en italia o el país alarma
en europa por las la crisis política en
italia y es que precisamente dice el
país italia está acostumbrada como
decíamos a vivir en un caos
institucionalizado pero esta vez en
medio de una guerra que esto también ha
comportado divisiones en el ejecutivo y
con un escenario económico de extrema
volatilidad la ruptura se presenta como
una de las más absurdas inoportunas y
auto en los últimos tiempos otro tema el
momento rosa el funcionamiento el
norisring 1 esto tenía en vilo a todos
los países europeos sobre todo alemania
porque pues temían que esto no se
reanuda no se reanudará el acceso de gas
a europa recordemos 10 días en
mantenimiento no rosa exactamente y para
resumir un poco la posición de la prensa
rusa sobre todo la que llegaban en
favorable al kremlin la que sigue
publicando desde dentro de rusia
básicamente es como que la unión europea
ha hecho sonar las alarmas por nada
porque básicamente dice gazprom tal como
señalaba putin nunca ha fallado con el
cumplimiento de sus obligaciones y
precisan aunque se redujo el rostro 30
por ciento exactamente pero digamos que
es aseguraban que el suministro iba a
volver a reanudarse tras estos días de
parón de reparación y básicamente
señalan las palabras de von der leyen
diciendo que rusia hace chantaje a la
unión europea con el suministro de gas
algo que es bastante obvio en el
escenario de confrontación bélica actual
y todavía rusia sigue diciendo cómo lo
decía te acuerdas al principio de la
guerra y de occidente muchísimas gracias
rosa por esta revista de prensa
saludamos a nuestro primer invitado el
día